Now that we understand what's
possible with animated vectors,
let's walk through an example
of implementing them.
We'll return to this tick to cross
animation and implement them.
The first step is to create two vector
drawables, one for the tick, and
one for the cross.
Here are my drawables,
I'm generating the path using my
favorite drawing graphics package, and
then exporting the SVG and and
grabbing the path data from it.
Soon Android Studio will be
able to import SVG directly
as a vector drawable.
A pro tip that I found helpful is
to create a resources file to keep
all of the attributes of
an animation together.
Here I'm calling it tickcross.
For example,
we'll need to reference the path data
from a couple of different places.
So saving it as a string resource and
then referencing it makes it easy.
Next we create animators for
each of the steps that are changing.
Here's an example that
morphs the ticks across.
See how it references the strings
we specified in the resources
as the from and to states.
Finally, we create
an animated-vector drawable
which connects the image
to the animator.
For example,
this animated-vector drawable acts
on the ic_cross vector drawable.
It targets one of the path sections
by name here, the crosspath.
And then specifies and
animator to run on it,
here running the cross_to_tick
animation we just looked up.
Once we have all of
the moving parts together,
we can show the drawable
in an imageView.
And start the animation
when appropriate.
Perhaps in response to
an event like a click.
You can find the full
source code to this demo
linked in the instructor's notes.
Fun details like this are a great
way to entertain your users and
show some personality in your app.